양자 텔레포테이션이라는 말은 공상과학 소설에나 나올 법한 얘기처럼 들릴 수 있지만, 오늘 에피소드에서 이야기할 것처럼
Qiskit in the Classroom에서는 양자 통신과
네트워킹에 실제로 존재하고 매우 유용한 기술이에요. Qiskit in the Classroom에 오신 걸 환영해요. 이 시리즈에서는 Qiskit을 활용해서 몇 가지 핵심적인
양자 컴퓨팅 관련 강의에서 자주 다루는 개념들을 살펴볼 거예요. 각 영상에는 인터랙티브 모듈이 함께 제공되는데
설명란에 링크가 있으니 꼭 확인해 보세요. 텔레포테이션은 이제 공상과학이나 판타지에서 자주 등장하는
소재가 됐어요. 어떤 사람이나 물체가 한 장소에서 사라져서 순간적으로 다른 곳에 나타나는 거죠.
정말 멋진 일이겠지만 아쉽게도 적어도 이런 종류의 텔레포테이션은 불가능해요. 우주의
속도 제한을 어기게 되거든요. 빛보다 빠르게 이동할 수 있는 건 없으니까요. 하지만 양자 텔레포테이션은
가능해요. 양자 텔레포테이션에서는 물질이 아니라 정보가 두
먼 위치 사이에서 전송될 수 있어요. 필요한 건 각 위치에 하나씩 있는 얽힌 입자 쌍과 두 위치 사이에서 고전적인
정보를 전달할 수 있는 방법뿐이에요. 이 프로토콜은 1993년에
IBM의 Charles Bennett을 포함한 양자 과학자 팀이 개발했어요. 공상과학 버전과 비슷하게
양자 정보가 한 위치에서 사라져서 중간 공간을 거치지 않고 멀리 떨어진 다른 위치에
나타나기 때문에 양자 텔레포테이션이라고 불렀어요. 마법처럼 들릴 수 있지만, 곧 보게 되겠지만 전혀
신비롭거나 마법 같은 건 없어요. 양자 얽힘 현상과 고전적인
통신이 가능하게 해주는 거예요. 오늘은 양자 텔레포테이션 프로토콜이 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴보고, 그다음에
실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 직접 실행해서 IBM 양자 프로세서의 한쪽에서 다른 쪽으로 qubit의 상태를 텔레포트해 볼 거예요.
자, 양자 텔레포테이션이 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴볼게요. Alice와 Bob이라는 두 사람이 서로 멀리
떨어져 있다고 해봐요. Alice가 qubit을 하나 갖고 있다고 해봐요. 편의상 qubit Q라고 부를게요. 그리고 이 qubit은 어떤
미지의 양자 상태 sq에 있고, alpha 0과 alpha 1은 복소수예요.
Alice는 자신의 상태를 Bob에게 보내고 싶지만 qubit 자체를 보낼 방법이 없어요. Bob이
너무 멀리 있을 수도 있고, 아니면 Bob이 정확히 어디 있는지도 모를 수 있으니까요. 다행히
두 사람은 이미 얽힌 qubit 쌍 A와 B를 공유하고 있는데, Alice는 qubit A를 갖고 Bob은 qubit B를 갖고 있어요. 그리고
이 qubit들은 얽혀 있어요. 얽혀 있다는 건 두 qubit이 큰 거리로 떨어져 있어도
고전 물리학으로는 설명할 수 없는 방식으로 상태가 서로 연관되어 있다는 거예요. 이 얽힌 쌍은
Ebit이라고 불리는 것으로, 양자 컴퓨팅과 통신에서 자원으로 활용할 수 있어요.
이 경우에 Alice는 EBIT을 자원으로 사용해서 자신의 양자 정보를 Bob에게 전송할 수 있어요. 어떻게 하는지 보려면
이 세 qubit의 결합 상태를 써보는 것부터 시작해 봐요. qubit들을 다소 임의적인 순서로 정렬했지만
Qiskit에서 실험을 실행할 때 편리한 순서예요. Qiskit에서 qubit을 정렬하는 표준 방식은
오른쪽에서 왼쪽이에요. 그래서 qubit 0의 상태는 오른쪽에 나타나게 돼요.
상태를 조금 더 펼쳐서 이렇게 다시 써볼게요. 그다음 텔레포테이션 프로토콜의 첫 번째 단계는
Alice가 C-NOT gate를 사용해서 자신의 데이터 qubit을 EBIT qubit의 절반과 얽히게 하는 거예요. C-NOT 또는 controlled-NOT
gate는 제어 qubit의 상태에 따라 타겟 qubit이라는 하나의 qubit 상태를 변화시켜요.
제어 qubit이 상태 0에 있으면 타겟에는 아무 일도 일어나지 않아요. 그리고 제어 qubit이
상태 1에 있으면 타겟 qubit이 뒤집혀요. 이 경우에 Alice의 데이터 qubit Q가 제어 qubit이 되고
Ebit qubit A가 타겟 qubit이 돼요. 처음 두 항은 C-NOT에 의해 전혀 바뀌지 않았지만
마지막 두 항은 제어 qubit Q가 상태 1에 있었기 때문에 바뀌었어요. 그다음 Alice는
데이터 qubit Q에 Hadamard gate를 적용하는데, 이 gate는 상태 0을 1/2 곱하기 (0 + 1) 상태로, 상태 1을
1/2 곱하기 (0 - 1) 상태로 바꿔줘요. 원하시면 직접 채워볼 수 있는 간단한 대수 계산을 여기서는 건너뛸게요.
몇 가지 항을 재정리하면 이런 상태가 나와요. 이제 Alice와 Bob의 세 qubit
얽힌 상태는 완전히 뒤죽박죽처럼 보여요. 하지만 Alice가 자신의 qubit을 둘 다 측정하면 어떤 일이 일어나는지 봐요. 세
qubit 상태는 이 네 가지
항 중 하나로 부분적으로 붕괴돼요. 그리고 각각의 경우에 Bob에게는 Alice의
초기 미지 상태와 관련된 진폭을 가진 중첩 상태가 남아요. 진폭은 alpha 0과 alpha 1임을 기억하세요. 그래서
예를 들어 Alice가 두 qubit을 모두 0으로 측정하면 Bob의 상태는 이 항으로 붕괴되는데, 바로 Alice가 텔레포트하려 했던 원래
미지 상태예요. 하지만 Alice가 qubit A에서 0, qubit Q에서 1을 측정하면 Bob의
상태는 이것이 돼요. 이 상태는 Bob이
여기서 이 부호를 뒤집을 Z gate를 적용하면 qubit Q의 원래 상태로 변환될 수 있어요. 하지만 Bob은
Alice가 측정한 걸 알기 전까지는 이걸 해야 한다는 걸 몰라요. 그래서 프로토콜의 다음 단계는 Alice가 Bob에게 전화해서
자신의 두 측정값을 알려주는 거예요. 그걸 알고 나면 Bob은 자신의 qubit에 어떤 연산을 수행해야 Alice의
원래 상태와 일치시킬 수 있는지 알게 돼요. 여기 네 가지 가능한 측정값과 그 측정값에 따라 Bob이
자신의 qubit에 수행해야 할 네 가지 가능한 연산 표가 있어요. Bob은 자신의 qubit을 Alice의 원래 qubit과 일치시키기 위해 Z gate, X gate, 또는 둘 다 적용해야 할 수도 있어요.
Alice가 Bob에게 전화하는 이 마지막 단계가 바로 순서대로
양자 텔레포테이션이 인과율을 어기지 않는 이유예요. Alice가 측정했을 때 Bob의 상태는 즉시 붕괴되지만
Bob은 Alice가 측정한 걸 알려주기 전까지 그 상태에서 어떤 정보도 얻을 수 없어요. 그리고
그 통화는 빛의 속도에 제한을 받아요. 지금까지 굉장히 자세한 수학 내용을 다뤘으니 엄청난
사실, 즉 방금 우리가 양자 정보를 텔레포트했다는 게 묻혀버렸을 수도 있어요. 하지만 정말 대단한 거예요. 얽힘을
자원으로 사용함으로써 Alice는 자신이 갖고 있는 양자 정보를 소멸시키는 측정을 할 수 있고, 그게
Bob이 있는 멀리 떨어진 위치에 나타나게 돼요. 이 거리는 수백, 심지어 수천 킬로미터가 될 수 있어요. 더 놀라운 건
이 프로토콜은 Alice가 Bob의 위치를 정확히 알 필요조차 없어요. 두 사람이 Ebit을 공유하고
고전적인 방식으로 통신할 수 있다면, 양자 텔레포테이션은 작동해요. 그럼 이게 어떻게 동작하는지
Qiskit으로 직접 확인하고, 실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 양자 상태를 텔레포트해 볼게요.
세 개의 qubit으로 시작할 거예요. 데이터 qubit Q와, E bit을 구성할 qubit A, B가 각각 하나씩이에요.
먼저 E bit을 만들어요. qubit A에 Hadamard를 적용하고, 이어서 C-NOT을
A와 B 사이에 적용해서 원하는 얽힘 상태를 만들어요.
그 다음, Alice의 qubit Q를 임의의 양자 상태로 준비해요. 이 박스에 U라고 표시된 임의의 유니터리를 적용하면 돼요.
그리고 텔레포테이션이 시작돼요. 먼저 qubit Q와 A 사이에 C-NOT을 적용하고, 그 다음 qubit Q에
Hadamard를 적용해요. 그런 다음 측정을 해서 상태를 부분적으로 붕괴시키면, Bob의 qubit B만 중첩 상태로 남아요.
이 시점에서 Alice가 Bob에게 연락해서 자신이 측정한 결과를 알려줘요. 그러면 Bob은
그 측정값에 따라 gate를 적용해요. 빨간 테두리로 표시된 박스들은 조건부 gate를 나타내요. 첫 번째 박스는
qubit A가 1로 측정되면 Bob이 자신의 qubit에 X gate를 적용한다는 뜻이에요.
두 번째는, qubit Q가 1로 측정되면 Z gate도 적용한다는 뜻이에요.
이제 Bob의 qubit은 Alice의 qubit이 유니터리 gate를 거친 이후의 상태와 동일한 상태가 돼요.
모든 게 계획대로 진행됐다면, 양자 상태를 텔레포트한 거예요. 그런데 어떻게 확인할 수 있을까요? 같은
circuit을 실행하되, 작은 변경을 하나 해볼게요.
여기서는 circuit 맨 끝에 유니터리를 하나 더 추가했어요. Bob의 qubit에 적용되는 이 유니터리는
처음에 Alice의 qubit에 적용한 유니터리의 역행렬이에요. 이 첫 번째 gate가
Bob의 qubit에 텔레포트된 양자 상태를 만들었다면, 이 역 gate는 그것을 되돌려서 Bob의 qubit을 다시 0
상태로 만들어야 해요. 하지만 이렇게 하면 텔레포테이션의 결과물을 없애버리는 거잖아요. 그래서 실제로
텔레포트된 상태로 무언가를 하고 싶다면 이렇게 하면 안 되고, 진짜 알 수 없는 양자
상태라면 되돌릴 유니터리를 적용하는 것 자체가 불가능해요. 어쨌든, 이건 순전히 진단 목적으로
텔레포테이션이 성공했는지 확인하기 위한 거예요. Bob의 qubit을 측정했을 때 0 상태라면, 텔레포테이션이
성공했다고 볼 수 있어요. 프로토콜이 예상대로 작동한다는 걸 확인했다면, 이
마지막 유니터리를 제거하고 텔레포트된 상태로 실제 작업을 할 수 있어요. 하지만 지금은 일단 잘 되는지 확인해 볼게요.
양자 컴퓨터에서 circuit을 실행해 봐요. Qiskit의 primitive sampler를 사용해서 이 circuit을
여러 번 실행하고 측정 결과에 대한 통계를 모을 거예요. Alice의 상태를 Bob에게 완벽하게 텔레포트했다면
매번 Bob의 qubit은 0으로 측정될 텐데, 환경 노이즈와 gate의 불완전함 때문에
Bob의 qubit이 1이 되는 경우도 생겨요. 하지만 대부분의
경우 Bob의 qubit이 0으로 측정된다면 성공이라고 볼 수 있어요. 여기 세 qubit 측정 결과의
히스토그램이 있어요. Bob의 측정값은 각 3비트 문자열의 첫 번째 자리에 표시돼요. 예상대로,
Bob의 비트가 0인 네 가지 결과가 나머지 넷보다 훨씬 자주 나와요. 이렇게 해서 양자 상태를
텔레포트하는 데 성공했어요. 그런데 얼마나 멀리 텔레포트한 걸까요? 이건
사용한 양자 프로세서의 모든 qubit 지도예요. 이번 실험에서는 이 세 qubit만 사용했어요.
Alice의 qubit은 여기, Bob의 qubit은 여기였어요. 거의 바로 옆에 있었던 거예요. 사실
swap gate 몇 개만 써도 똑같이 할 수 있었을 거예요. swap gate는 이름처럼 두 qubit의 양자 상태를 바꿔줘요.
양자 텔레포테이션은 양자 정보를 먼 거리로 전달할 때 유용하고,
실제로 수백 킬로미터 거리의 양자 상태 텔레포테이션도 이미 이뤄졌어요. 이번 실험에서는 칩
크기의 한계가 있지만, 양자 컴퓨터 내의 두
멀리 떨어진 qubit 사이에서 텔레포테이션을 해보면 좀 더 인상적일 거예요. 한번 해볼게요. 새 circuit 도식이에요.
좀 더 복잡해 보이지만, 본질적으로 달라진 건 없고, 이제 Alice와 Bob이 공유 EBIT을 만든 다음
서로 분리돼요. 선과 X 기호들로 이루어진 이 부분은 swap gate를 나타내는데,
Alice와 Bob의 상태를 다른 qubit으로 이동시켜요. Alice는 qubit 1로 올라가고
Bob은 qubit 12로 내려가요. 그런 다음 Alice는 qubit 0에서
이 유니터리로 임의의 상태를 만들어요. Alice와 Bob이 이미
분리된 이후에 상태를 만드는 거예요. 즉, Bob은 이미 멀리 떨어져 있어요.
그다음은 이전과 동일하게 텔레포테이션 프로토콜이 진행되고, Bob이 조건부 연산을 마치면 Alice의 원래 상태를 갖게 돼요.
역 유니터리 gate를 적용한 후 Bob의 qubit이
0 상태인지 확인해요. 이번에도 대부분의 경우 Bob의 qubit이 0 상태로 확인됐어요.
텔레포테이션 성공이에요.
다만 성공률이 Alice와 Bob이 바로 옆에 있을 때만큼은 높지 않아요. swap gate가 많으면
비용이 커지고 EBIT이 조금 열화될 수 있거든요. 양자 텔레포테이션이 마법처럼 보일 수도 있지만,
결국 필요한 건 얽힘, 고전적인 통신 채널, 그리고 약간의 기발한 아이디어예요. 1993년에 발표된 원래
이 영상에서 다룬 제안은 양자 gate
텔레포테이션 같은 다른 프로토콜의 기반이 됐고, 양자 계산과 통신에 있어 핵심적인 요소예요.
실험적으로도 과학자들은 양자 텔레포테이션의 한계를 계속 밀어붙이고 있어요. 심지어
지구의 실험실과 1,400km 상공의 위성 사이에서 광자의 양자 상태를 텔레포트하거나,
잡음이 있는 고전 인터넷 케이블을 통해 양자 상태를 텔레포트하는 데도 성공했어요. 직접 양자 상태를 텔레포트해 보고 싶다면,
설명란에 링크된 양자 텔레포테이션 모듈을 확인해 보세요. 시청해 주셔서 감사하고,
다음 시간에 또 만나요.